it's movie review Friday and today we
are talking about what is probably one
of my favorite horror films weird flip
of the 70s if not of all time if this
movie scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid
it is very disturbing and creepy it's
just it's very very odd and yet eerie
and this inspired many a Skinny Puppy
song this movie you know samples from
this movie dialogue a dialogue in Skinny
Puppy many people will say The Shining
is a classic horror yeah and I would
agree with that but I think the tenant
is the tenant is probably the French
version of The Shining in other words
yeah a French horror masterpiece it has
a lot of similar elements to it a weird
music weird story you're not sure what
you're seeing is real or not you don't
know if this is a ghost you don't know
if this is insanity the story unfolds
the way it wants to unfold it's taking
its time it ratchets up pressure on you
and the main character and then it
releases the pressure and then it
ratchets it back up again and then it
releases the pressure so you're not sure
if you and the main character are
imagining this are you getting paranoid
you don't know eventually all hell
breaks loose oh yeah yeah
now the tenant is from 1976 famously
directed by Roman Polanski now this is
the third film in his so called
apartment trilogy which is not in a
trilogy in the true sense of the word in
that it's like a single overarching
story it's just three movies that share
a similar setting a similar theme things
like that the first two movies of course
are repulsion which came out in 1965
1966 I believe and Rosemary's Baby which
came out in 1968 so all three of these
movies set in an apartment all deal with
paranoia madness of varying types
repulsion was kind of about you know
start Catherine Deneuve and she was in
her apart
it was kind of like an outward
manifestation of her spiraling madness
and her you know kind of her weird
sexual repression and stuff like that
Rosemary's Baby using the apartment more
as kind of like womb metaphor how her
neighbors who were the satanic cult
obviously have spoiler alert right who
were kind of like invading her life
invading her womb things of that nature
this one is kind of more the tenant is
kind of more a meditation on loss of
identity yeah a little bit of xenophobia
yeah things like that it's interesting
to me this is actually based on a novel
which was called the chimeric tenant and
the novel I haven't read it but from
other people who have read it and you
know kind of reading a breakdown of it
it seems the story is very similar the
tone is very similar to the movie so it
seems like Polanski did a pretty
faithful adaptation of the book now
Roman Polanski he chose to play the main
character himself yeah that was a good
move yes as creepy as that little dude
is you know especially you know what we
know about him now that creepiness kind
of moves backwards in time and infects
this movie yeah he's just a creepy man
yeah he's very creepy right but like I
said I think the reason that he
specifically wanted to play the main
character in this was because a lot of
it sort of mirrored his own life I mean
he was you know he was a Polish Jew and
you know living in Nazi under Nazi
occupation he had to hide out from Nazis
his parents were put in the
concentration camps you know and he
moved from country to country so there's
a lot of stuff in this because the main
character who has only noticed
trelkovsky he's never given a first name
he is also a Polish immigrant he's
living in Paris he is a French citizen
he makes great pains to tell people but
there's still something of everyone
being sort of like hostile toward him
because he's
outsider he's a stranger and so a lot of
that kind of infuses this movie so I
think that's kind of why yeah you're not
wanted his own experience to mirror that
of the case you're not sure whether or
not the characters imagining this or if
it's real - yeah and they never really
they never resolve it resolve it one way
or the other which is one of the things
I really like about this movie and
there's a lot that I really like about
this movie now as much as I love I love
repulsion
I love Rosemary's Baby I mean Rosemary's
Baby those are also two of my favorite
horror movies ever I don't know if the
tenant is objectively a better film than
Rosemary's Baby but I would argue that
it's a creepier film than Rosemary's
Baby oh yeah by far there's just
something really even when this movie
cuz like but this movie is very long
it's two hours
um and it's some people say oh it's kind
of rambling or kind of slow which I
didn't really find I don't I find it
very yeah I find it very intriguing it's
very your countryside this guy's mind
they shrug they're trying to endear this
character to you so you care about him
and you know he's trying to be normal
but this guy's going insane the the
question is is why yeah because he's
going insane just like the Tennant
before him yeah the one that was the the
girl that was there before and there's a
bunch of little clues that make you
wonder is she under some kind of ghostly
or attack
is he coming under oppression or
possession what is it is he just going
crazy is he imagining all this and it's
up to you to decide because they never
really find out yeah but it's just a
weird movie and people know a body
horror and movies about this is like
identity horror yeah there's a real
famous scene where Polanski's drunk
laying down on the back of his bed he's
got this beautiful woman trying to
undress him and climb in bed with him
and he's going and he starts rambling
and philosophize and you know he's like
you know once there was a man who lost
his right arm and you know he asked to
that arm to be buried and the
authorities said no and you know and he
goes but you know body parts are a part
of us you know but what what happens if
I cut off my
what do I see me and my arm you know and
here's what if I cut off both my arm
what do I see my arms and me yeah and
then and then he's goes you you you you
take out my stomach my intestines what
do I see me and I see me and my
intestines then I cut off my head what
do I see
do I say me and my head hurt I said me
and my body he's just going on what
right does my head I have to call itself
me yeah and that's really I think that's
really what this movie is about whoa
what right do you have to call yourself
you so it's and you'll see what I'm
talking about when you see this movie
because yeah this guy's losing this
identity feel yeah like I don't anywhere
they don't want to give too much away
but you have to get a little bit away
just because there's so much stuff that
I love in this movie the whole theme
now trelkovsky 'he's character even from
the beginning is portrayed as very timid
he's very mouthy and he's in contrast to
like his workmates and contrast other
people he almost seems like even though
he's trying not to be a burden or a
bother to anyone it's almost like
everyone around him is so loud and so
obnoxious and they see him as an
imposition even when he's trying not to
be yeah so there's kind of a lot of that
he a brief summary of the plot you know
he has moved to I don't know if he lived
in Paris before they don't really say
anything about his life before they
don't say why he's looking for an
apartment they don't say and like what
his specific job is they show up at his
office a couple times but they don't say
specifically he's just some kind of
office worker and it's it's very Kafka
esque in that way he's sort of like an
everyman he's like he's almost like a
blank slate kind of he's just this mousy
regular little guy now at the beginning
of the movie he for some reason needs a
new apartment and he finds out through a
relative that this one apartment in this
building is vacant because it's former
tenant simone choule who was an
Egyptologist which kind of plays into
some of the imagery later on has
attempted suicide by jumping out of the
window of the apartment and crashing
through the glass awning that's below
yeah
now she didn't die immediately so she's
still in the hospital
now he kind of feels bad about taking
the apartment because she's still alive
Apartments are really hard to Foote
apartments are really hard to come by
even though this I mean they're asking
like a ridiculous deposit for this and
right it doesn't even have its own
bathroom you have to go down the hall
and use a shared bathroom and stuff like
that but he really needs an apartment
for whatever reason he ends up in this
apartment this concrete broken-down
apartment with all this girl's stuff
still and all of her stuff is still
right and she ends up dying soon after
and he's living in this dead girl's
apartment with all her stuff and slowly
he starts to realize that everyone
around him is starting to slowly treat
him as that girl they start forcing her
back brand of cigarettes on him they
start forcing hot chocolate on him
instead of coffee
they just do weird [ __ ] and you don't
know if he's imagining this or if yeah
the people in the environment are really
ganging up on him to force him into the
role of this girl yeah I don't know the
weird that it has like such and and also
you should say too that um that he's
given her male like even after yes dad
and that's like that's the beginning of
it appears to be a big conspiracy to
drive this [ __ ] insane or he believes
it or he believes it to me right but
then there's other things that happen
that seem like it possibly could be
paranormal or possibly hallucinations or
a mixture of them both and maybe maybe
possession you don't know ya know I mean
it could be read either way yeah because
the thing is I mean obviously he was
making a thematic statement about loss
of identity one of the hallmarks of
Tchaikovsky's character besides him
being you know very quiet very mousy
trying not to offend anyone and yet
offending people anyone because like all
his neighbors are like complaining about
him making noise even when he wasn't
there they complain about other tenants
in the building who he never sees it's
like it's all this really weird kind of
[ __ ] but another hallmark of his
character is that
he's constantly lying not in a way that
um not a malicious not in a malicious
way it's just kind of like it's almost
to make things easier for him easier
from you well like he'll lie even when
he doesn't have to write a good way to
look at this movie is for those of you
guys who have also taken taking the
advice to watch The Changeling a
changeling it would be like an example
of a realistic haunting of a house
that's been inhabitant by a very strong
character very strong-willed man who can
confront the truth that's what you have
with the changeling this is kind of the
opposite this is kind of a weaker man in
a creepy apartment whose doesn't have a
strong sense of identity and he's
breaking down and going insane this may
be a haunting this may be some kind of a
weird possession or it may just be
insanity you don't know because this guy
really can't confront truth the reality
if you asked me yeah it seems like that
to me
and I think the title of it to the
tenant obviously refers to simone choule
the previous tenant refers to him a
tenant of the apartment so not only does
it refer to him being a physical tenant
of an apartment of a place but it also
he's also a metaphorical tenant in
someone else's identity ya know what I
mean so it's it's almost kind of like
that because I I do think in a way
because I think even from the beginning
he has some mental issues like I said he
doesn't have a particularly strong self
sense of self or a sense of identity of
his own it's like he doesn't really have
any friends he just hangs out with all
these people who work with him who are
nothing like him they're all like
obnoxious jerks you know he he just
seems to never stands up for himself he
never stands up for himself he's very
you know he's he's very people pleasing
he's trying to be which is why when he
moves into this apartment and everyone
seems initially rather hostile yeah
toward him or imposing on him like Oh
take this hot chocolate that's what she
always used to have or have
this brand of cigarettes we don't have
the ones that you have for us and there
are that you usually smoke and he just
kind of rolls with it yeah but I think
that that's what kind of contributes to
his you know slow eroding away of his
own personality which he didn't have
much of to start with yeah so it's
almost kind of like he takes up the
mantle of this other woman's personality
just it's a really cool like I said I
think it's interesting how the name of
the book in French the French the
English translation of the French is
actually the chimeric Tennant right not
just the Tennant right but so they're
actually talking about some kind of
hybrid identity switch and it's also
there's also kind of like a time loop
going on as well yeah which is kind of
interesting and like I said the
Egyptology angle I think that's the only
angle that's actually not present in the
book but I think the reason that he
added that to the movie was because the
Egyptians had a particular belief that
not so it's not so much like because I
was reading a review of this earlier and
somebody made this point which I really
liked
they're like it's not so much like
Hinduism words you know like
reincarnation and stuff but the
Egyptians kind of believe is everything
was happening all the time like it once
and it was just this a turtle kind of
you know everything happening and also
they had that thing about taking body
parts out and putting them in jars yeah
which is kind of analogous to what he
finds in his apartment okay
so it's almost kind of like a magical
like the parts of your body almost like
it's magical fetishes right you know
what I mean
so they kind of so that kind of hints at
a supernatural element but like I said
the coolest thing about this is that it
never specifies it could be read as a
guy going crazy because of what happened
in the apartment before like he's
thinking about it too much and things
like that it could be read as a creepy
conspiracy against him
you know analogous set it can also be
read as a supernatural possession the
apartment itself might have some kind of
or the whole building might have
of sinister energy to it or something
like that it could really be read any of
those ways which i think is what makes
it such a brilliant horror film and why
it's so creepy it's a masterpiece if you
ask me yeah I agree and I think it has
even though there's a lot of there's
elements of black humour and it there's
elements of camp in it almost yeah but
the creepy scenes I mean I saw this
movie when I was pretty young
probably like a young teenager and then
I saw it again a couple years ago and
then we watched it again yesterday and
the scenes from this movie there are
several scenes from this movie which
have really stuck with me over the years
just because they are so unsettling yeah
you know what I mean and I think I
mentioned what I was talking about when
I did the review on David Lynch's
Mulholland Drive scenes like that this
kind of like weird identity switching
like displacement type of things like
I'm over here I'm over there like Who am
I and said yes scenes like that have
always really really creeped me out and
I'm not entirely sure why that is like I
wrote a big long s I think David I think
David Lynch was inspired by this movie
actually well I don't know if he was so
much inspired by this he was probably
inspired more by Ingmar Bergman and you
know some earlier stuff with the whole
because Ingmar Bergman did like persona
and stuff like that about you know
switching identities and losing sense of
self and stuff so it's kind of in
surrealism it's a pretty common through
line you know as a theme in particular
movies and I think that was just
something that he picked up on but it's
the same kind of thing here but this one
like I said I think it's cool that the
three movies in this trilogy they kind
of take this theme of paranoia and stuff
like that but they do different [ __ ]
with it
and this one like I said kind of focuses
mostly on loss of identity but also on
how society imposes its will on you or
makes you conform to it there's a lot of
that going on in this too not just
because he's a foreigner like living in
a country that isn't as Oh
he feels like an outsider and people
make him feel like an outsider but also
in a sense because they're trying to get
him to adhere to their rules which in a
way are he's not able to adhere to them
even though he tries and I think that's
one of the things that kind of causes
his mind to start to unravel and you
know he starts to associate more and
more with the woman who lived in the
apartment before who and I have seen
this suggested more than one place might
have been similarly persecuted because
she was also quote-unquote nonconformist
because she was a lesbian right so
they're trying to he's trying to make
the point that society is going to try
to like hammer you into this little yeah
box and it could drive you crazy you
know because even if you try they're
still not gonna let you I've never seen
it as a kid and it just waked me out
because it was difficult you know I was
kind of losing my sense of realism yeah
like what was real you know what is this
guy is he imagining this is this really
happening some things seem like they're
like it's really happening
yeah other things don't really you don't
you know it's not it's not as weird to
say like Eraserhead by any means right
kind of more along the lines of the
shining kinda it is kind of similar
automatically similar similarly and I
like that he doesn't really make a
distinction between reality and fantasy
yeah everything is kind of shot the same
so you don't really get a sense of oh
he's just imagining this part it could
be and it and it does seem even from
very early in the movie I mean for the
first like 4550 minutes of this movie
I'm gonna say it almost doesn't even
seem like a horror movie I mean there's
a couple little creepy things that
happen yeah it doesn't play the horror
movie game no not really you know is it
on its own terms yeah it's usually
termed as a psychological thriller which
I guess is the closest approximation of
what it's John Roos but I found a lot of
the imagery that comes around later in
the movie you know particularly after
Simone dies in the hospital a lot of the
stuff that he sees is just like really
really unnerving I find and the way
shot is very unnerving and even like the
apartment in the apartment building
itself almost becomes like a character
and it's something it's kind of cry me
and run down and [ __ ] like that
so I think that really helps in giving
this like a really creepy feel yeah and
it's definitely one of my favorite one
of my favorite horror movies and one of
the ones that creeped me out the most
like and had the most the imagery that's
stuck in my head over the years yeah I
was able to get it on DVD I think
there's only five dollars actually
there's a brand-new one I think that's
five dollars yeah you can't get it on
blu-ray
yeah weirdly it hasn't written release
on blu-ray oh my why I don't know if you
can see it on YouTube or not maybe do
you think I watched it on YouTube but
that was many years ago so it might have
been taken down by Nara like dailymotion
or just by the DVD it's worth it you
yeah it's obviously it's not as well
known as Rosemary's Baby so it's not as
easily available but you might be able
to find a free one somewhere and DVDs
are fairly cheap but like I said I don't
think it's Adams a French movie it's in
English some of the people are dubbed in
it but Polanski he doesn't most of all
are dubbed yeah because Isabelle Adjani
is in this and I'm pretty sure that that
is not her voice okay yeah this was
actually one of her early films this is
before she didn't ask for a two in
possession and all those that she's
better known for but uh she's in this
although she's almost unrecognizable
those glasses so that'll do it for this
latest movie review remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe and
all your social media and if you'd like
to support the show remember to go to
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress calm and there
is a link in the sidebar to a paypal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation and remember to tune in for our
regular episodes every tuesday and our
movie reviews every Friday and until
next time bye take out
give me something that me and Mike
[Applause]
[Music]